ja mein thema also schwangerschafts
abbrüche was ich heute mitbringen die
sind hier unter bestimmten bedingungen
auch bis zu drei monaten straffrei
möglich will jetzt auch gar nicht in der
frist rütteln das überhaupt nicht
intention ich möchte nur dass die frauen
die sich dafür entscheiden eine gute
medizinische versorgung kommen und wir
sehen dass immer weniger ärzte den
eingriff vornehmen in bayern ich zum
teil ganze region abo ich überhaupt
niemanden finden gottseidank streichen
jetzt diesen paragraphen 219 awo ärzte
noch nicht mal neutral aufklären durften
dass sie den eingriff vornehmen und
medizinstudenten haben das überhaupt
nicht in ihrem regulären curriculum drin
diesen eingriff auch praktisch zu üben
in berlin an sich dann studenten
zusammen getan und das ganze an einer
pattaya
wirklich das kann es nicht sein wir
brauchen eine gute medizinische
versorgung um hier auch eine
selbstbestimmung der frauen zu
ermöglichen leider ist das noch nicht
erfolgt und ich plädiere ich erhoffe mir
auch von weiteren rechtlichen änderungen
besseren rahmenbedingungen dass wir dann
damit auch die versorgung der frauen
verbessern
herr schubert möchte mitgehen bei der
these sehr bedingt auch da geht es mir
eigentlich um die metaebene also mir
geht es zunächst einmal darum warum
möchte eine frau ihr kind abtreiben und
ich denke das ist für mich die brennende
frage in so einer situation ja das ist
dann dazu kommt oder nicht kommt ist für
mich ein zweiter aspekt da kann man da
will ich mich auch gar nicht äußern dazu
sondern für mich ist es als ganzes
mediziner wichtig dass wir auch da
gucken vielmehr schauen was sind die
bedingungen warum eine frau den gedanken
hat die sorge hat die angst hat dieses
kind auf die welt zu bringen und es
nicht auf die welt bringen will das ist
das schönste was es gibt ja ein kind zu
kriegen und für manche frauen ist es
nicht es ist nicht so umgeben und die
frage ist warum und das ist für mich
brennen das willig diskutiert haben und
nicht auf der mechanischen seite den
medizinstudenten
mitgeben in seinen studien
ausbildung würde es zum beispiel die
update angeboten jahres freiwillig sagen
ich könnte nie kollege werden facharzt
werden und habe das noch nie im meister
wie der ökologe ist vornehm hier ja und
damit kommen wir zum problem der
strafbank dadurch dass ich das im
strafrecht immer noch drin hab das ist
ja so geregelt ich kann das machen wir
bestimmten voraussetzungen die an sich
richtig sind
148 stunden muss man noch mal überlegen
zu pro familia
oder anderen beratungsstellen vor allem
die dreimonatsfrist das ist sicherlich
richtig
gibt es bestimmte ausnahmen noch mal
aber der punkt ist ja dadurch dass ich
das im strafrecht letztlich
kriminalisiert habe und unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen zu sagen der gesetzgeber
von so einer strafe absieht bewegen sich
ärzte in so einem graubereich
bewegen sich natürlich auch kann ich das
auch letztlich schwer verpflichtend in
unserem curriculum vorsehen und sagen
auch krankenhäuser das wollen wir
eigentlich nicht so richtig aber das
kann es nicht sein wenn wir wollen dass
frauen das legal vornehmen können unter
diesen bedingungen dann muss es auch
möglich sein dass ich auf eine gute
medizinische infrastruktur zurückgreifen
kann das ist dann in dem moment an
eingriff wie jeder andere und ehrlich
gesagt muss ich ihm sagen ich finds
vermessen wenn sie sagen ich kann ihre
sorge verstehen dass sie sagen müssen
gucken warum haben die frauen denn sorge
ein kind zu bekommen aber letztendlich
geht uns dass diese abwägung doch
eigentlich gar nicht stand der staat
muss eine gute infrastruktur für
familien geben stimme ich ihnen
vollkommen zu aber die einzelne
entscheidung der frau die habe ich an
der stelle überhaupt nicht zu bewerten
wenn sie sich innerhalb dieser drei
monats frist bewegen können die
bedingungen unserer gesellschaft
verändern davon habe ich geredet ich hab
nicht geredet dass die frau ist sich
öffnen muss warum sie das tut und nicht
tut darum geht es mir nicht es geht mir
um ein komplexes zusammenspiel es geht
nur in gesellschaft und kultur und und
das was sie gesagt haben das ist für
mich zunächst einmal die frage in
welcher realität leben wäre und die
möchte ich jetzt erstmal anschauen bevor
ich überhaupt solche ganz wichtigen als
fläche die sie angesprochen haben ich
will das ja nicht verringern oder
vermindern die problematik angesprochen
haben die zinsen ein aber sowas von mega
andere ist aber so was für mich ja ich
meine da gibt es genug menschen die das
nicht tun wollen und ärzte die das nicht
tun wollen und mit ihrer ärztlichen
aufgaben überhaupt nicht verwinden
können dass gibt es auch und den muss
ich die freiheit lassen dass sie das
nicht machen wollen da fängt ganz an das
würde mich interessieren ja das auch so
sehr wie legasthenie also das soll eine
ärztliche leistung werden sie kennen die
diskussion assistierter suizid das ist
gerade aktuell wieder schwer diskutiert
soll aus ihrer sicht der schwangerschaft
eine ärztliche leistung so werden das
quasi jeder gynäkologe ist anbieten muss
oder soll das freigestellt sein nein wir
wollen ja niemanden verpflichten das
vorzunehmen aber ich möchte natürlich
durch einen guten gesetzlichen rahmen
dafür sorgen dass ihm die ärzte dies
vornehmen erstens nicht bedrängt werden
und an den pranger gestellt werden und
ein zugang von frauen in die praxis gar
nicht möglich ist weil ich
abtreibungsgegner davor habe und dieser
arzt sich überlegt ob er diese praxis
weiter betreibt das kann es nicht sein
wir brauchen wir sind gesehen guten ja
und wir müssen wir sie
in der situation unter diesen
bedingungen rausnehmen